welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and kang the conqueror
appears to be marvel's new phase for big
bad
with confirmation that jonathan majors
is playing a major role in ant-man 3
that multiple sources are reported to be
king now you might have seen majors in
lovecraft country on hbo a
great show that you should definitely be
watching or in spike lee's to five
bloods on netflix alongside chadwick
boseman
and kang is a fella we've been talking
about since i made an hour's worth of
videos breaking down two
seconds of footage from loki on disney
plus here i'm gonna dive
deeper into who kang is and how this
guy's gonna tie into the ant-man 3 plot
based on everything we know
but also how kang is the missing link
that closes other quantum tunnels a
possibility
leaving us with one clear path forward
for how marvel is gonna set up
loki ant-man three the fantastic four
and
a future young avengers title spoiler
warning for
everything marvel's future because now
there is a future once more
don't okay kang is marvel's ultimate
time travel villain a master of
countless timelines from a distant
future
amassing wealth and weaponry from
various histories
on various planets to create a dynasty
of himself
all feeding kang prime at the very end
of all time he's coming to conflict with
the avengers with the fantastic four he
kidnaps him he traps them back in time
he's just kind of an all-around time
dick now in the mcu
avengers end game broke time with their
time heist and going forward in this age
of timelessness
kang is king he's essentially what tony
stark was unknowingly referring to when
he said
he messed with time it tends to mess
back you'll see but in later comics kang
was suggested to
have been the younger man nathaniel
richards who is a 31st century
descendant of reed richards from the
fantastic four if he saw some reports
saying that majors was playing nathaniel
richards father to read richards those
reports are wrong
wrong sir wrong but before i continue
thanks to
vesti for sponsoring this video and you
may have noticed it from my good mood
this video that
yeah i've been wearing them all did you
bestie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and weatherproof
they're super breathable too so they
don't let any liquid in but they do let
the air move
out they also have an anti-microbial
insole so your little piggies will stay
smelling fresh and messy's shoes are
super stretchy
like a rubber band they fit like a sock
but they only weigh 175 grams which is
the same amount as an iphone without
your big ass
case they're made with this cool
material that keeps your feet warm in
cold weather and helps heat escape
during those steamy months
which here in hot hot la was pretty
great when i had to do some outdoor
stuff
i am hosing down my roof right now but
uh-oh wait a minute
i'm getting water all over my shoes yet
my little piggies are bone dry
everything's coming up eric get 25
off your own pair of bessie shoes when
you use my link in the video's
description
click that link for 25 off these cool
weatherproof knit sneakers so kang
blipped up on
our radar when the early loki footage
showed the god of mischief in a prisoner
jumpsuit stamped with tva
for time variance authority marvel's
time cops and time enforcement agency
tasked with investigating and patching
all the ruptures to the time stream and
it stands to reason that the tva's most
wanted from the comics kang
would also tie into that plot but kang
now confirmed as the villain of ant-man
3
bridges all of this together because the
biggest lingering mystery from ant-man
and the wasp was that hidden city in the
quantum realm
which director peyton reed confirmed to
be an intentional easter egg planted for
a future title and based on this news it
appears that that city
is phronopolous chronopolis is kang's
home city-state located on the outskirts
of the timeless dimension limbo
with access points to every time era
that kang has conquered each city block
of chronopolis exists in its own time
period
and this makes sense chronopolis and
this quantum realm city have matching
domed appearances and you know if the
city's domed our man kang is homed
now the marvel cinematic universe
established the quantum realm as the
dimension containing
time vortexes which of course allow
branches into alternate timelines the
way most cities in world history were
constructed along key waterways mountain
passes crossroads i think kang
built this city on rock and roll but
more importantly at the nexus points of
his various bridges through time
janet van dyne didn't go into a time
vortex she steered clear of them and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you that is why
janet aged normally in the quantum realm
where scott lang
stayed young via time dilation and
traveled ahead five years into the
future
he did go into a time vortex in fact i
think scott's use of that time vortex
and all of the avengers hijacking time
vortex is an endgame is what has drawn
kang
into conflict with them kang is a master
of time that network of vortexes that
lead to the past
is a toll bridge that he lives under
he's the troll an ant-man and his
buddies just blew
right through this toll booth without
answering any of the riddles more
importantly kang
exists because the can of time travel
worms has been opened
and the time stream has flowed in a
specific destined path
the avengers changed that destiny with
the time heist
undoing thanos's snap so that half of
all life that was supposed to have been
dusted is now back
and thanos ain't i believe kang is kang
because he benefited from that
post-apocalyptic future and now he's
pissed that the avengers erase that
future from existence threatening his
existence
so i believe the loki disney plus series
will follow loki after
end game having violated the rules of
the time stream by breaking free of the
prime mcu timeline
now the tva is freaking out because the
multiverse is a
mess owen wilson's working overtime
trying to get it back in order kachow i
better be getting time and a half
i have no idea what i'm doing they must
know the avengers were involved but loki
is the one suspect they got their hands
on his only path to freedom is to help
them
investigate this chain of time crimes
that have now erupted
since the time heists and all those time
crimes it turns out they're committed by
the same rogue criminal
a figure that by the end of loki season
1 is established as
kang ant-man 3 will then pick up this
mystery peyton reed recently promised
the third film will be more sprawling
than the first two
with a very different visual template by
that
i think he is referring to kang a name
that janet van dyne will recognize
as a tyrant from her decades in the
quantum realm the reason she stayed away
from that city
and its time vortexes but when they
return to the quantum realm to
investigate that city they find it
deserted
tang's shining retirement home is in
ruins since the avengers shattered his
destiny with their time heist
ever since kang has been going back
through the time stream restoring his
paradise block by block by creating
paradoxes across the multiverse and
pissing off the tva but his ultimate
destination the logical one for any time
traveler the birth of time travel itself
in this universe the invention of pym
particles hank
pym invented pimp articles sometime
before 1970 since his past self had them
an end game in that year
so he must have developed that text
sometime during the 1960s
when younger michael douglas might have
been working alongside scientists like
reed richards sue storm johnny storm ben
grimm
and victor von doom peyton reed has long
dreamed of directing a fantastic four
movie set in 1960s new york i think
ant-man 3
is finally giving him that opportunity
you could even work in madman era john
slattery howard stark it's perfect so i
think kang is returning to that era to
steal the original pymtech to make
himself once more
the master of time creating countless
new branch timelines in which the
avengers are never
able to complete the time heist and
thwart thanos thus
restoring kang's throne and by bringing
the fantastic four to the present via
the quantum realm
that quantum energy that gave janet van
dyne her healing powers
could be what gives the fantastic four
and doom their powers
we could even learn that stark tower
used to be their base of operations the
baxter building in the 60s
and now in the future they can reclaim
it which explains those clues we saw in
spider-man part from whom
meanwhile kang's existence theoretically
means his younger self
31st century nathaniel richards could
meet teenage cassie lange a partnership
between iron lad and stature
in this future young avengers team-up
that marvel appears to definitely be
moving toward look we're gonna go
more into the mcu phase four
implications with kang in thursday's
episode of rogue theory be sure to check
it out you can discuss these theories
directly with me on new rockstar's
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
new rockstars follow me on instagram at
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
you